how did the church
transition to sunday worship was it the
lord's day
all right how did the church transition
good question
the jews always give the romans
headaches
and we understand why no one likes to be
conquered the jews of
all the peoples the romans conquered the
jews probably
were the most troublesome of all that
bless them for that
because no one likes to be conquered
they were always revolting always
rebelling
there was a rebellion in 135
i think the rebellion of barkoba i think
that's the name because of that
judaism was abolished or banned or made
illegal
by the roman power but even before that
under emperor
vespasian who i believe reigned from 69
to 79
a few decades after christ he abolished
the sanhedrin
and the priesthood during his reign
which means judaism was very very
unpopular among the romans now under
emperor hadrian
who reigned from 117 i believe 138 139
he made sabbath keeping illegal
with all these uh this opposition
to sabbath keeping from the roman powers
christian you see christians were
closely identified with jews
and for good reason christ was a jew all
the apostles were jews
the first converts to the teachings of
christ were jews who came out of judaism
to follow the new teachings of christ
and so christians were closely
associated with the jews particularly
because they were keeping the jewish
sabbath and i use the word jewish
sabbath carefully
the sabbath is god's sabbath not a
jewish sabbath
as time passed christians began to
figure out
what can we do to distance ourselves
from the jews so that the romans will
understand we are not jews we are
christians
they began keeping both days sunday and
saturday
now something else happened saturday
used to be a day of celebration the day
of feasting
that was transferred to sunday as a
celebration of the resurrection of
christ
and saturday was made a day of fasting
well all people love to eat
so people began to observe sunday more
often than saturday because saturday
became
a day of misery and fasting and fasting
whereas sunday was a day of feasting and
celebration
so these things contributed to a gradual
it was a certain
centuries to a gradual movement away
from
saturday to sunday as a day of worship
and of course when constantine passes
law
in 321 when he became a christian
so-called
and began trying to act like a christian
it was easy then for christians to
follow the example of the emperor
but again it took several centuries for
there to be a
full-blown departure from the
seventh-day sabbath but god has
always had people in remote places
keeping the sabbath
and the country of ethiopia is one such
example hundreds of years ago
where they kept at some point they kept
both the sabbath has never been
eradicated
because as long as god exists as creator
there will always be his lord jesus said
think not them come to destroy the law
or the prophets
have not come to destroy but to fulfill
for verily i say unto you till heaven
and earth pass
one jaw one tittle shall in no wise pass
from the law
and that means all ten so yes
this is the reasons why sunday
observance became popular
because of the conditions in society the
roman power
opposed to the jews the abolition of the
priesthood the abolition of the
sanhedrin
the making illegal of sabbath keeping
making sunday a feast day sabbath
a fast day all of these things
contributed to a gradual
shift away from god's day
to a man-made day of worship